[Music]
listen my first memories of Berlin were
the months that I spent in an asylum
seekers home
those are my earliest memories I can
remember the long hallways the linoleum
floors
there were many cribs for children and
many other people from Asia how nuyen
was born in 1977 in Laos this photograph
of her extended family was taken before
her birth her father was critical of the
government and in 1979 her family fled
to Thailand how nuyen was the youngest
of four siblings a year later she
arrived in Berlin meanwhile she has her
own family sharing meals together with
her husband and children is very
important to her Asia food plays a very
big role it's at the center of
everything at big family celebrations -
there's always a lot of food good food
it's always the highlight even nowadays
when there's a family celebration
everyone looks forward to the food and
of course to spending time with your
family when you all get together my
niece
how nuyen originally trained as a
foreign language clerk
[Music]
in 2011 she and her two brothers opened
a restaurant in the NOI current district
of berlin chez Dom features dishes from
southeastern Asia
domina status and my father's name is
done officially our last name is new Yin
because the person who applied for our
permission to come here put down the
name new Yin which is a very common
Vietnamese name but our real name is
done that's why we decided to use that
name for our restaurant and Shay is a
nod to Indochina which Louis is a part
of in which my grandfather and
great-grandfather worked for the French
sometimes as cooks that's why we thought
it was a good fit papaya salad is a
traditional ocean dish which is served
in many different ways it's usually
eaten with fermented shrimp in an
unusual twist the ingredients are
crushed with a mortar and pestle papaya
salad is a melange of flavors combining
the sweetness of papaya and sugar a
salty fish sauce the sourness of lemon
and the spicy heat of chilies
[Music]
do not water secured Sciences Ocean
cuisine is definitely spicy hot we have
many dishes that have some heat to them
but they aren't just spicy they all have
their own distinct flavor combinations
because we also use a lot of herbs and
spices in Asian cooking we tend to use
many more ingredients than in European
cuisine and it tends to be more
expensive because the herbs aren't as
widely available so they do cost more
Augustus produced Vasa is where Noah
Cowan meets Berlin's Kreuzberg district
it's an area that's changed a lot in
recent years
rents here used to be affordable which
threw many young people to the district
that was followed by the rise of a
vibrant restaurant scene once a rather
rundown area it's now become trendy
there's very colorful very edgy and also
multicultural it used to be a bit more
of a ghetto I guess you could say the
area I live in which isn't that far from
my restaurant used to be a place where
most people didn't want to live today
it's almost impossible to find a place
here
when the restaurant is busy how nuyen
helps out in the kitchen ever since her
brothers left the business her cousin
and mother have done the cooking
[Music]
somebody when you clear hit some tongue
hey job Kim
Sam Sam no
[Music]